[Music]
okay so this is my review of the new
Netflix series unbelievable now
obviously this is based off of a true
story and the thing you got to realize
here it's actually based off a Pulitzer
prize-winning story and they have
adapted it now into this miniseries and
the other important thing is that you
can see now this is directed by three
different people so the first three
episodes are actually directed by the
director of The Kids Are Alright Lisa
Cholodenko the next three are directed
by Michael dinner and the last two are
directed by Susannah grant and that's
very important for the series because I
definitely could tell the different
styles and had many thoughts in
particular about different episodes so
let's jump right into that so to me
episode 1 of the series was one of the
most important episodes of in a show
I've seen in a long time and what I mean
by that is there's been so many shows
and movies in history that tackle the
issue of rape but what was so important
about this was that in this pilot
episode you're seeing that
yeah we're getting a graphic rape scene
and it's just jumps right into it which
I appreciate that it jumped it right
into the story and didn't waste time but
what's more important is the aftermath
and how people handle someone accusing
somebody of rape being assaulted and you
see with Maria our lead character played
brilliantly by Kaitlyn Dever who just
started the movie book-smart that it is
a torturous process and can be super
abusive and you see this so brilliantly
shown through this episode because I
loved they decide when she goes to the
hospital and when she talks to these
detectives it's at like fluorescent
light we've all been in when we're at
hospitals and it's just all just very
bright lighting that gives the intensity
to it and almost like that depressing
atmosphere and that they gave everybody
just a real look and that includes Marie
here where they're not like putting all
this fake makeup on her
keeping her look her best they just let
it be natural and real that it made you
feel like oh my god this like is a real
thing that happened this is how this
stuff goes about and you see that it
burn we depicts how much pressure they
give this girl when they're
interrogating her and why someone would
change what they said and you hear about
all these assault cases and why someone
might go back on what they said and they
go hi they were lying and how that
happens and how it's a traumatic
experience just the aftermath - and
that's just a lot of props the director
here and also Kaitlyn Dever she plays
this so well I really like how they
showed her hands shaking and it would
cut to her thinking about the incident
while these detectives were just going
hard at her it was really hard to watch
but it was necessary it was important so
people can understand this and I don't
think I've watched anything that was so
clear and opened my mind to what really
goes on if someone goes and reports a
rape and this is really detailed and
shows you and that's how you had to do
this to really make that conversation
grow even stronger and they do a good
job of putting you in her shoes that
suffocating feeling again going to a lot
of close-ups here and really to the
nurses they show it's like they make it
seem and feel like in her shoes you feel
like you're like this product or an
animal they're just treating her like
the robotic nurses or just taking DNA
and no one's even asking her really if
she's okay or if she's ready for this
and what really worked about that going
with that angle in the pilot and just
focusing on her story was that when we
get introduced to Merritt Weaver's
character detective Karen in Episode two
we actually see a different rape case
and how she handles it compared to the
male cops which is another important
dialogue this show is having here where
wait a minute that really is super
importance here in just a field like
detective work with gender because you
could see a woman Merritt Weaver's
character Karen how she handles a very
almost identical situation and does it
completely
differently she's so caring to the
victim she's letting her take her time
she's not making assumptions she's not
forcing her to do anything she's always
putting the victim first and trusting
the victims words and that is the huge
difference here and that was just bright
as day and they did such a good job with
that again props the director now for
those first two episodes you can see
that this director who did The Kids Are
Alright is really good at just that
interpersonal drama human drama and
showing that now these first year
episode she directed though I was
feeling that episode one was excellent
that's definitely one of the best of
this series but two and three especially
three for me fumbled around a lot and
and I mean by that is the side of it
with the detectives with Tony Colette's
character grace and merit Weaver's Karen
because there was like a tone it had
that was like very CSI uh points or any
CBS kind of detective drama or got a
little hokey the music the comedy was a
little forced and flat there was one
scene with Karen's victim that she was
handling where that grows with her
boyfriend and he has a line I'm a
mathematician I believe in numbers I was
crying my eyes out how ridiculous that
wasn't how corny that was there certain
like things like that that felt very
like CBS in those first three episodes
particularly two and three so I feel
like Lisa Cholodenko strength was in
covering Murray's story but not as great
in doing the detective parts of it and
keeping that entertaining in a good pace
it was just again jumbled around and
felt like some it's just a different
tone than the rest of show eventually go
to that would be some of my criticism I
do like her choice of introducing Murray
and then introducing Merritt Wever in
the next episode and then introducing
Tony Cleto everyone's waiting for
episode 3 that was cool and gave him
time to build build their characters
which I appreciated so I always nitpick
things but a big problem for me was they
opened the show with the title on the
bottom giving you the setting and it
says Oaks Dale but for some reason they
refused to give you the state in that
situation or the year which was
really frustrating to me because then in
Episode two it starts when we see
Merritt Weaver's character Karen it
tells us it's clearly in Colorado in
2011 so I'm like okay so this is a
different time period than the first
episode but what the hell when was the
first episode was it before was it after
then you figure out through other things
when it was but I didn't know what state
or a timeline Murray's story was in from
the first episode until I looked at the
episode two description not even in the
show itself and they didn't actually
show that it took place Murray's story
in Washington until in 2008 clearly with
a title until I kept a--so three or four
which was just absurd to me they they
did the whole season basically that the
times they decided to give you the
setting of the town of the year it was
all over the place they randomly would
it remind you to Washington in the year
but then they just wouldn't for a couple
episodes they're like what the hell
where are we and what year is this and
then it just appalled me that if they
were gonna do that they decide the first
episode in the first scene not to tell
you the year or the state which was
frustrating to me that's me nitpicking
but that was just a weird decision I did
not agree with I'm enjoying the story
but please try not to make it so
confusing in that sense it's just a
simple thing you know I don't see the
upside I'm not telling us the year man I
feel so much for Murray here there's
just parts where everyone just goes
against her when it's come out that
she's live and wow these at-risk kids
are real jerks huh
none of them were supportive to her and
just all hated her after that that was a
little much you would think at least one
of them would have a soul and especially
the counselors giving her a curfew and
then she gets betrayed by her foster mom
Judith when she goes to the cops and
says she thinks she's lying and it was
really tough to watch to when her foster
dad basically tells her he doesn't want
her at the house alone with her because
he doesn't want to risk anyone thinking
anything or ruin his reputation so hard
to watch it felt like watching that old
90s in the collodion movie Harriet the
Spy where it's so hard to watch just one
innocent girl victim being just
ridiculed and not believed by and put
down by so many people it's a tough
watch you know but again is very
necessary for us to see this and I love
the show wasn't afraid of doing that
I did like to here was this show
effectively flipped our usual norms in
TV and positions we see in life where
you know the females are bosses the
males are interns and it's it's really
good they did a good job with Merritt
Weaver here as the boss yelling at the
men in the office like to move quicker
to have more push to get this done it a
really good commentary just in general
throughout this series about where men
don't take these rape allegations as
seriously as women do when they just
tiptoe and I love that especially Tony
Colette's character grace just was so
hard and gung-ho about that like come on
let's let's take this seriously let's go
and I thought that was a really good
just eye-opening experience to watch I
was like this team they said up to here
where you're seeing they're connecting
the dots that this might be a cop and
that it was these lady cops banding
together to make sure not to spill that
too soon because it could risk that
operation again just opened her eyes to
how much corruption there still is
especially with trying to throw a cop in
jail but again these couple early
episodes I thought the humor was a
little forced and off a little cringy
especially the scene where Mia is on the
computer and she's like I got other
information cuz I told them it was for
Veterans Day list and then all the girls
in the office smirk like that kind of
stuff to me is a little cheesy and on
the nose in the beginning to is a little
frustrating cuz it seemed like every
single guy was an idiot or just a dummy
so like obviously you already can see
through a couple of them you get the
point so it was like kind of a little
bit overkill 2 or again that can also if
you want to get other people to get a
point that you're trying to make
politically it's like bring them into it
realistically don't over-the-top do it
that it's like shoving down the throat
either there's it's just not as
effective I think if you want to get
everybody's eye and the people you
really want to convert to your
philosophy make it as real as possible
and I think they really nail that in
later episodes with the female guy
perspective going on and how it handles
in an office space like that I really
like the theme here where you see that
these two foster moms have said they've
had similar experiences to Marie
but Colleen gets that hey that doesn't
mean that it's exactly the same and she
can react a different way than we
possibly did and that was just a good
message there too because that could
happen with victims talking about other
victims where everyone reacts
differently so I like that and also that
Colleen's the foster mom who wanted to
take action or just mess things up
because she just wanted to go away just
like the cops didn't want to even like
look at it and that's a big theme that
we'll go more into later on they read
ress and I love how they set up these
two detectives together with Karen and
grace where toni collette grace is more
of the pessimist here the realist she's
not about God she's not religious where
Merritt Weaver's character Karen she is
actually of faith and religion and she's
also of hope she is optimistic she comes
off set but she really is the optimist
in this relationship and that also works
perfectly because she's the newer
detective here where Toni Collette has
been around the block and that just
worked perfectly and was perfectly cast
for that and how they kind of both
worked off each other perfectly with
that and they balanced each other as a
team in that area I thought that was
excellent and it also led to some really
good humor between the two of them later
on just that jokes about each other's
lifestyles I think that just really
worked great I also enjoyed the humor I
thought did work it got more better
towards the middle was actually the
intern here the guy I think him slipping
up was great and that he finally got
Redemption because you see a lot of
those guy interns and offices now and it
worked well with the older lady in the
office too that it was her intern and
she was bragging about how good she was
making him that was great and that's
played by Dale Dickey she did a great
job so in my head watching the series
realize in the first three we're
directed by Lisa :
I think she was the best person to it
was the one an episode one was excellent
two and three wasn't crazy about there's
also points where I was starting to lose
a lot of interest I just kind of felt
like again that CBS feeling of a crime
show and dull but then when it gets
passed off episode 4 - episode 6 is
where Michael dinner directs it and I
really felt like episode 5 is where this
show found its groove and it's good
pacing
and again where the detective stuff got
way better engine feel cheesy and from
episode five on it doesn't look back and
there was a really really strong scene
for me with Toni Collette when she says
I don't understand why the FBI
detectives not outraged why isn't there
that wanting to solve this and move and
and what was really good was Merritt
Wever telling her you're totally right
you're not wrong but we gotta get this
done and you screaming into the wind
isn't changing anything there's a
different way to do it and I think this
is just really a good commentary just
about outrage and how everyone gets
outraged about so much stuff which is
always in the right intention but that
also that part of working together with
these people show them how to do this
and it's more like do the work than less
talk you know what I'm saying like I
thought that worked really well and then
this one of the humours started clicking
like when they did the nose goes where
someone had to go to Kansas like all
that chemistry started clicking kind of
midway in the show and then there's just
like some crazy scenes where Toni
Colette's going to check on this cop
that they're suspicious of and he spits
in her face at the bar that was crazy
and I really really loved here with
Murray where there's a symbolism of you
constantly get mentioned about her
wanting to drive and get her license and
it was like such a payoff because
they're setting up midway where she
keeps going to DMV she wants to either
like she's telling people about it she
takes a road test but fails it and it's
not till the end that she's driving and
it's again her finally taking the wheel
in her life and learning to drive and it
also blends so well with just when she
was actually thinking about when she was
first raped and she's running on the
beach it's like you know her losing that
hope she talks about later on and that
innocence and just optimism in life and
thinking of good and then giving up on
that coz of that assault and at the end
ending up at the beach and recapturing
that optimism again due to good in the
world which was the two detectives which
we'll get more into but again they set
it up here and that was some beautiful
beautiful symbolism with her what made
me just literally tear a lot in these
last
so they set up well here was with Murray
being a foster kid they showed the
loneliness she goes through and also
being a victim and not being listened to
by anybody there they did such a good
job of portraying that loneliness and
just seems like in the DMV where
everyone's with the parent she's alone
and there's her losing her friends again
like that was tough and it's also just
an example and a commentary on foster
care to where when these people get
older like people think they just go on
with the life and get really good jobs
and get a degree and it's not always the
case and most times it isn't and it's
something our country has to reevaluate
because a lot of these people end up
homeless too so there is that just like
loneliness effect going on here in a
commentary in that and it just adds more
weight to this whole case and story and
I mean drivin have to say is for Toni
Collette and Mary Weaver were impeccable
as well their chemistry was off the
charts and I love the humor Toni club
brings to this especially just her
talking about her God is just alcohol
and dogs and I love it comes back around
to that Merritt Wever character was
inspired by her and that she learned so
much from her and it became this mentor
relationship now another standout seen
from you is actually in Episode six
where it really showed me to that
Merritt Wever can handle some big
monologues and some big emotional scenes
and what I love about her style of
acting is that she reminds me of a Mark
Ruffalo type where she's very real and
realistic there's never any hamming up
her you never feel like she's just
acting and performing it just feels like
a normal person and that's something
that needs to be applauded too like I
really respect actresses and actors who
can do that and she does it so well I
thought her best scene in this whole
series was this scene where her and Toni
are sitting down and there she Toni
brings out the cards right and they kind
of are really talking about their
philosophies here just about how to
handle being this detective in this dark
job and making sure you still have a
life and family and other things to
value and you know it was almost like
symbolic to of the cards of like you
know this was her Tony being a mentor
here and giving her
and kind of giving her her side of the
table here in this game they play and it
was kind of like Merritt Wever was like
oh she has the best hand here and kind
of lays it on Tony and she was right
here we're like it's not any knock on
Tony's character but it was more of a
like just showing you the level you can
go to someone who really is for doing
the best they can for a victim and that
was merits character here where she
talks about a story where you know she
was like with coworkers and they wanted
to just grab a beer with her and loosen
up and she missed a big thing in her
case and more abuse happened because of
her taking that break and her gut was
telling her don't go home yet and
following that gut so it's just
interesting you see the contrast it's
not preaching to you what's right or
wrong it's just showing you like
different levels of commitment and I
thought that was just really powerful
stuff and does show you there's really
really good people out there and then
you get kaitlyn dever here just knocks
out of the park as Murray here with when
she goes to the counselor and has her
monologue about zombie apocalypse oh my
god
this is also incredible writing as well
besides just the acting and you see this
story you got to connect here obviously
the zombies are these monster rapists
terrible people in the world but she's
talking about how humans are the ones in
these zombie apocalypse which can be
even more dangerous you had to worry
about which is all these people in her
life who are enabling this these zombies
and just ignoring her needs and she
talks about in order to survive assume
everyone is your enemy and that is like
the defense mechanism right there and
you've seen that in apocalypse shows as
well and it just shows you that relation
to how a rape survivor could feel and
they had a really good sequence here I
love it was very stylistic where they're
showing McCarthy is caught right and
it's in the he's in the jail Sun it's
flashing between him and Merritt
Weaver's character just looking at the
evidence and seeing her faces the truth
of this monster and then find the
panties in the amp which is crazy and
that came full circle - and what was
great - about this Murray councillor
thing is when she went in there she was
drenched in his pouring rain behind her
in that scene which is just again
beautiful production design what a shot
and once she has her breakthrough
counselor it stops raining so really
good detail there and that is when I
started raining out of my eyes
that was beautiful and I'm trying not to
cry on camera now but man this was some
emotional stuff here in these last
couple episodes tears will probably come
out and we talked about the last episode
and the counselor was excellent as well
it's just a good counselor she knew had
to get her to break open was doing the
complete opposite again of those men
detectives from the beginning it's just
letting her speak on her terms and that
they didn't even have to speak if she
didn't want to and what it was
beautifully synched was when Mara is
finding the evidence and finding answers
and getting a win here and then Maria on
the other end is having this huge
breakthrough it's all synced together
back and forth and it goes to the title
where merit even says it's unbelievable
and that isn't just meaning unbelievable
they've got this guy and got a win here
and found this from all their hard work
it's also just the title meaning to
things where the story is also about
this girl hasn't been believed
unbelievable so it's like it really
works perfect title as well so credit to
that and so when we jump to episode
seven and eight this is where the show
went to masterpiece levels and that is
when the director became Susanna grant
my god did she do an incredible job
standing ovation for her if this camera
was taller I would do it but just
knowing in my heart doing that just
starts off the bat with them clicking
through here in Episode seven all these
victims from files on the computer which
was so powerful the numbers of sky the
number people who affected lives he
ruined and in this powerful Episode
seven just this scene if you're gonna
like submit an Emmy for this show it
should be the scene where she's having
Marie do the why people lie monologue
and they're looking at these pictures
and then they see her picture and she's
talking about how even with good people
you thought you could trust this the
truth is just inconvenient to them and
that's why they'll go away from it
especially like someone like a Judith
and right when you know the detectives
say she looks 12 man I was who I was
tearing like crazy there that was just
so well earned and so well just betrayed
and then I thought after Stannis with
seven how the hell are you gonna top
that episode I thought they were
actually gonna end it there
and then I saw there's another episode
and it was just as good
I do think 7 was the best but 8 was also
fantastic that we got pay off too we're
like in this story that the original
detective gets his karma here and he
looks terrible and she Toni Collette
emails him the pic of the victim it's
like wow it's like straight truth right
in his face it's just amazing when he
goes to see Toni Collette and he sees
all the work they do on the table it's
like yeah this is the stuff you didn't
do and could have and should have been
doing and props to that actor as well I
don't know his name but he was really
good
that's a tough role to pull off and I
got some tears too when he went to admit
to her that he messed up at the her job
and he I mean it gave me some you know
feeling of kind of I guess like okay
maybe this guy has some sort of soul
there that which besides the other
detective I was with him was just a
grump and never apologizes but I'm happy
he manned up and actually went and face
to face to tell her that cuz he royally
screwed up and you know sometimes I run
away or they deny it still and then she
opens a check and it's five hundred
dollars from the city oh my god you
always read about stories like this in
the news but then when you're there and
you're in the store and you see it man
does that piss you off and you see she
lawyers up smartly and this is just an
incredible story here by Marie and her
doing this especially at her age and not
having all this guidance to tell her
this it's just awesome and that she
wanted the money for the reasons of
justice not just for money you know and
that showed that really clear to its
settlements cuz some people ago they're
doing it for the money like no she was
doing this for what was right and making
a statement and Laurie lets her know
like it's gonna be 150,000 they're
paying to bury this and she just wanted
to be over because he was even saying
he'd get more and she was like no I just
wanted to make my point in a way so yeah
and it was just powerful her naming all
this stuff why five hundred and
originally was too cheap and everything
she'd been through and lost her friends
lost her family everything so her job
who it just showed you again that power
of what one rape incident an awful
person can do to someone's life and it
haunts them forever it's not just the
rape it's the aftermath and I was just
so relieved that this is a good
happy ending where this man gets 327
years in prison
what a win it was just great seeing the
two detectives
fist bump man that was awesome seeing
the victims in the courtroom get their
justice and I love to that they had this
storyline going on with Merritt Weaver's
husband we're talking about what is max
the knife's Nick why is he max the knife
hit her husband and I thought it would
be something bad or mysterious they're
kind of teasing you that way but I like
the ended on a good note so it led this
all to a very happy ending which I loved
and hopeful because this show was so
dark and such a like story of just
giving that conversation and getting it
going but giving hope to it too and it
was really interesting when they
actually interview the rapist McCarthy
and he's just bringing up that fact to
like every time I get away with one I
get better and better
I should have been caught on the first
one he's like my DNA was everywhere like
I was just expecting to get caught so it
shows you to like that's how important
it is yeah like when there's a first
case like of assault or rape you have to
give 110% especially these detectives
and not wait till they've done like six
or seven people because then they just
get good these guys so it's like that
was a really good commentary as well and
I'm I like that Murray went back to made
an apology
at least that guy said he's sorry and
she's like do better I love that but of
course the other detective doesn't even
say anything he just looks at her what
did it what a jerk that's just a crappy
person right there
so we're where he got super amazing and
powerful and emotional to me was when
she's on the beach Murray and she calls
Karen and Murray's on the beach and the
symbolism is again when I was talking
about before where the beach is like
that was her just view of hope and
happiness and good in the world and she
had lost that when she was raped but
when she heard what they did she gained
it back and what that beautifully shows
is that good people can affect people
anywhere from any distance and you may
not even know you're helping someone
like anyone can change the world like
how hopeful is the message is that and
that is what Merritt Wever did and just
the way Katelyn Deaver was saying her
lines like
how powerfully written it was or she was
like if the world is this bad so why
would I want to be in it just giving us
that total and look into her mind of why
she almost jumped off the bridge earlier
in the season and she said the thing
that just gave her that hope again
wasn't about the money it wasn't the guy
getting locked up
it was hearing what those two female
detectives did I wake up now and I
imagine good things happening really
something and you know what when she
drives off now she's learned to drive
it's one of her dreams and she's learned
to drive in life and take the wheel and
she drives on the sunset and she smiles
like unbelievable and just the narration
of her saying thank you to her man that
was that was something that's top 10
powerful moment for me and just anything
I've ever watched like man did that pay
off and again Susannah grant you
couldn't have done these last two
episodes better
you took a show that I thought was
pretty good and like put at this level
so it's tough to rate this one I would
if every episode was a level of seven
and eight I'd probably have given this
series of ten and then you can go to
five throughs five and six we're really
good - it wasn't seven and eight but
they were really good but my problems a
little bit were one through four
especially three was like fumbled a bit
so I can't forget that but okay sorry
not including one one was great - so I
would say the best episodes are 1 7 & 8
& 5 & 6 were good three and four and two
and so I got to be reasonable as a whole
season rating so I think it's fair to
give it a nine point four but I mean
some of these episodes were I could say
seven and eight were tens but as a whole
scale nine point four again just little
things I'm always in to pick stuff
trying to keep my bar high but again the
title thing really pissed me off that
again the first scene we don't know what
year it is or what state it's in like
come on and yeah I think that this is
one of the most important shows that's
ever come out in recent time I think
everyone should watch this no matter who
you are no matter what circumstance I
learned so much from this and it was so
powerful and effective and convincing I
kind of remind me the end of big.little
last season one not gonna spoil having
watched it but it has that kind of vibe
how this
like oh my god like this is so earned
this is powerful it's believable I felt
like I've become a smarter and more
aware person because of this and yeah it
was hell ver I Dan de ghin the three
leaves here Merritt Wever Kaitlyn Dever
Toni Collette
amazing Toni Collette is so likable she
had so much humor to this I'm sure she
improvised a lot of that merit we was so
good at just being real and just playing
well someone sensitive but and not a
pushover though and just really really
complicated character but did it look
made it look so easy and again kaitlyn
dever man she's got to get nominated at
least for this for the emmy and if she
wins she totally deserves it this is a
perfect performance by her she and this
one note excellent I mean I'm blown away
by her performance and those Street all
the serve to be nominated and Kaitlyn
Dever deserves hands-down to win that
award unless someone comes up with a
better performance but that's gonna be
tough to beat and I think that everyone
the side care girl casts a great really
good casting and good cinematography
good setting I think the production is I
was really good lighting was OnPoint
everything had a nice tone to it again I
just feel like episode 2 3 4 the tanzil
off and it felt like CBS CSI but it
finds its groove 5 through 8 and that's
when the show becomes really good so
again 9 point 4 for me let me know you
thought this down below I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the whole season
anything I need seen that you like or
stuff you didn't like maybe they like
the series as a whole or maybe like 2
more than me so let me know please make
sure to subscribe to my channel I review
a bunch of TV shows movies and I also do
celebrity interviews as well you don't
wanna miss that
and please follow me at Steve rd1 on
Twitter Instagram for more of me and
I'll see you next time